check out our sponsors
nature's blends they specialize in
premium ethiopian black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends hope you guys are aware
inshallah
this is a poster i saw on khabib's
instagram and i found it really powerful
because it's a
reminder to every single one of us a
very very profound reminder
um and you know i believe he has
you know got consciousness of allah
subhanahu we see this many times
in his behavior how he was with his dad
etc we see that in him
um and the true understanding of tawheed
with his
not just by words verbally you know
talking about this and that but you can
genuinely see
that tawheed the worship of allah has
really hit his heart the way he is now
this is what he says and
this video he shared because it was his
father's anniversary death anniversary
and this is what he had to say and i'm
going to be reading that as we play this
video of his father which he posted
um feeding the horses
so he said it's been a year today since
my father is gone
this event has increased my belief
that in this world we own nothing
not our children not our parents not our
property
everything we have is temporary all
things belong to allah alone
and to him we shall return tie your
hearts to allah
stay more alone with him for a time will
come
when we will when we will all be put in
the grave
where we will all be alone where our
friends relatives
properties and connections will not be
there only our deeds
and our says report i'm sure
uh that's what it means now this is
absolutely a beautiful video in office
father
and i'm going to karen playing that on
the side brothers and sisters but one
thing i want to mention to you guys
wallahi
this is an absolute bitter reality and
allah wants us to divorce this dunya
continuously
he's giving you signs and signs and
signs over and over again
divorce the dunya divorce doesn't mean
you don't go to work
divorcing the dunya doesn't mean you can
have fun it's saying
carry the money or the dunya in your
hand
not in your heart brothers and sisters
all of us
we love to have jannah and go jannah but
none of us want to die
and that is a reality that is going to
come to every single one of us
imagine living the life prophet said
well i imagine standing in front of
allah
and you did not pray one salah you did
not give once in zakah
you did not fast once and even if you
did imagine brothers and sisters
here is a reality allah is telling you
your mom
your mom one life your mom is not going
to go in the grave
the mom i'm giving you it's not the mom
calls the mothers either
we can say one of the most merciful ones
to us in this life
even then allah is telling you nobody's
gonna come
when you hear death of loved ones
whoever it may be and you see
that their husband get married again or
their wife end up getting married again
that should be a reminder to you man
hold on a second if i die my wife
might get married again and that's
normal now you might not you might hate
the fault
but that is the reality that may happen
or she may not get married the point is
this that
eventually when you see different
people's moms crying and eventually
getting over it somehow it should tell
you
that would be your mom also or that
would be your dad also
or your wife or your husband or your kid
eventually they are going to get
over it because not because they want to
because they have no choice but to if
that
is the reality of this life that should
teach you if family is going to do this
let alone friends let alone property
let alone these things that are going to
be replaced the car that you drive
somebody else going to drive from
the way you drove it's going to be
driving you like that yeah the clothes
that you wear someone else is going to
probably wear it or it's going to go in
the bin
the house that you lived in the bed all
of it
imagine you are giving all this effort
to the dunya
entrepreneur trying to be something
prove a point to this person
and all you're doing is you are
bankrupting yourself in the hereafter
you're gaining you're thinking of
gaining something here but you're
bankrupting yourself in the hereafter
focus your attention in the hereafter
and while just as you turn your back on
your shadow it has no choice but to
follow you
the dunya will do the same and allah
will grant you
this life and the hereafter
and i'm going to end on this note
inshallah until next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh